meantime long lines and delays were  common across the valley today but  voters at one northeast valley location  had to wait even longer  voting machine malfunctions and a  breakdown made for a long day  county officials say a hardware failure  at the lowe's parking lot near craig and  losi  was the culprit one machine working  then that failed and then everything  just went  i've been down here since eight o'clock  this morning  but i was determined to get my boat in  today once officials were made aware i.t  technicians were sent to correct the  issue  the machine was down for about two hours  before voters were able to get started